يجب أن يكون عام 2022 هو العام الذي ننهي فيه
الوباء
[الموسيقى] ،
فهناك الآن
دليل ثابت على أن omicron
ينتشر بشكل أسرع
بكثير من متغير دلتا
ومن المرجح أن الأشخاص الذين
تم تطعيمهم أو تعافوا
من covid19
يمكن أن يصابوا
أو
يعادوا العدوى
[  الموسيقى]
بدلاً من تعزيز الطفل في
البلدان ذات الدخل المرتفع ، من الأفضل
تطعيم كبار السن في البلدان التي
لديها
كبار السن الذين لم يتم تطعيمهم
حتى اللقاحات الأولية
[موسيقى]
جميعنا
سئمنا من هذا الوباء الذي
نريد جميعًا أن ننفقه  قضاء الوقت مع
الأصدقاء والعائلة ،
نريد جميعًا العودة إلى
طبيعته ، أسرع طريقة للقيام بذلك هي أن نتخذ جميعًا
نحن
القادة
والأفراد القرارات الصعبة التي
يجب اتخاذها لحماية أنفسنا والآخرين
[موسيقى]